- Witaj w kursie „Zrozumieć
informację i obliczenia kwantowe".
Mam na imię John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym
IBM Quantum Education.
Celem tej serii jest zapewnienie ci
solidnego zrozumienia informacji i obliczeń kwantowych, co oznacza zagłębienie się w szczegóły techniczne
informacji kwantowej i zobaczenie, jak obliczenia kwantowe
naprawdę działają, co mogą, a czego nie mogą robić.
Jeśli jeszcze nie
oglądałeś/-aś wideo przeglądowego do tej serii, zachęcam cię, żebyś to zrobił/-a.
W tamtym wideo znajdziesz informacje o tym, jakie przygotowanie
jest zalecane przed tą serią, a także zarys
omawianych tematów.
Koniecznie zajrzyj też
do podręcznika Qiskit, który omawia te same
materiały co ta seria wideo, ale w formie pisanej,
a także zawiera
interaktywne elementy oraz interfejsy do sprzętu i oprogramowania, które pomogą ci lepiej zrozumieć
informację i obliczenia kwantowe. Linki do wideo przeglądowego i podręcznika Qiskit
znajdziesz w opisie.
To jest lekcja pierwsza
pierwszego modułu serii.
Moduł pierwszy omawia podstawy
informacji kwantowej, a w pierwszej lekcji skupimy się na tym, jak
działa informacja kwantowa
dla pojedynczych układów, co oznacza, że mamy
tylko jeden układ fizyczny lub urządzenie pewnego rodzaju, które
przechowuje informację kwantową
i rozważamy, jak ten
jeden układ lub urządzenie działa w izolacji.
W kolejnej lekcji omówimy, jak
działa informacja kwantowa, gdy mamy wiele układów, co pozwoli nam
opisać interesujące
i ważne pojęcia, takie jak algorytmy kwantowe korzystające z wielu qubitów
oraz protokoły kwantowe
z udziałem wielu osób, które przetwarzają informację kwantową i przesyłają ją
między sobą.
Jednak zanim przejdziemy do tych rozważań, sensowne jest zacząć od
stosunkowo prostego przypadku pojedynczego układu w izolacji,
częściowo dlatego, że dobrze jest zaczynać od rzeczy prostych, ale także dlatego, że jak zobaczymy, opis działania
informacji kwantowej
dla pojedynczych układów w izolacji prowadzi bardzo naturalnie i logicznie do opisu działania
dla wielu układów.
Oto krótki przegląd lekcji.
Zaczniemy od omówienia
informacji klasycznej.
Celem tej lekcji nie jest wyjaśnienie, jak
działa informacja klasyczna, ale wyjaśnienie, jak
działa informacja kwantowa,
ale żeby wyjaśnić, jak
działa informacja kwantowa, bardzo pomocne jest zacząć
od informacji klasycznej i używać jej jako
znajomego punktu odniesienia
podczas omawiania informacji kwantowej.
Na poziomie matematycznym informacja kwantowa i klasyczna mają dość podobne opisy, z pewnymi kluczowymi różnicami, oczywiście.
W rzeczywistości informacja kwantowa
nie jest wcale oddzielna od informacji klasycznej.
Jest rozszerzeniem
informacji klasycznej.
Faktem jest,
przynajmniej moim zdaniem, że naprawdę nie możesz
zrozumieć informacji kwantowej, jeśli nie rozumiesz
informacji klasycznej,
więc zaczynanie od informacji klasycznej
ma sens.
Spodziewam się, że te
treści będą znajome niektórym widzom, ale nawet jeśli je znasz, nie polecam ich pomijać.
Oprócz podkreślenia aspektów informacji klasycznej, które są najbardziej istotne dla
zrozumienia informacji kwantowej, w tej części przedstawimy
notację Diraca,
która jest standardowym sposobem,
jakiego będziemy używać do opisywania wektorów i
macierzy w całej serii.
Okazuje się, że notacja Diraca nie jest
specyficzna dla informacji kwantowej.
Może być równie dobrze stosowana w kontekście informacji klasycznej, jak i wielu innych zastosowań, gdzie pojawiają się wektory i macierze.
Następnie przejdziemy do informacji kwantowej, a konkretnie omówimy
reprezentację stanów kwantowych jako wektorów,
prosty rodzaj pomiaru zwany pomiarem w bazie standardowej oraz operacje unitarne, które opisują dyskretne zmiany czasowe
w układach kwantowych.
Ponownie, wszystko w kontekście
pojedynczych układów.
Zanim zaczniemy samą lekcję, warto wyjaśnić, że istnieją właściwie dwa opisy
informacji kwantowej: opis uproszczony, na którym będziemy się
skupiać w tej lekcji
i przez cały pierwszy moduł, oraz opis ogólny, który jest omawiany w późniejszym module, a konkretnie w
trzecim module serii.
Opis uproszczony,
zgodnie z nazwą, jest prostszy i zazwyczaj
poznawany jako pierwszy.
W opisie uproszczonym, jak już sugerowałem, stany kwantowe są reprezentowane przez wektory, a operacje są reprezentowane
przez macierze unitarne.
Ten opis informacji
kwantowej jest wystarczający do zrozumienia
większości algorytmów kwantowych,
więc nie jest nadmiernie uproszczony — to prawdziwa rzecz.
Jednak, jak odkryjemy
w trakcie kursu, ma pewne ograniczenia.
Na przykład, jeśli chcemy
modelować wpływ szumów na układy kwantowe, ten opis okazuje się niewystarczający.
WEBVTT
Opis ogólny natomiast
jest bardziej ogólny i ostatecznie mocniejszy
w sensie matematycznym.
W tym opisie stany kwantowe są reprezentowane przez specjalną klasę macierzy
zwanych macierzami gęstości,
a bardziej ogólna klasa
pomiarów i operacji może być opisana, w tym
na przykład szumy.
Jest w pełni zgodny z
opisem uproszczonym i w rzeczywistości można zasadniczo traktować
opis uproszczony
jako szczególny przypadek
opisu ogólnego, który obejmuje również informację klasyczną jako szczególny przypadek.
Jest też naprawdę piękny
w tym, jak to wszystko działa, więc gorąco zachęcam cię do poznania tego opisu ogólnego
gdy nadejdzie właściwy czas, ale opis uproszczony jest bardziej naturalnym miejscem na początek i właśnie od niego zaczniemy.
Zaczniemy od omówienia informacji klasycznej, mając na uwadze aspekty
informacji klasycznej, które są najbardziej istotne
dla informacji kwantowej
i sposobu jej matematycznego
opisu.
Wyobraź sobie, że mamy
układ fizyczny lub urządzenie pewnego rodzaju, które przechowuje informację.
Nadamy temu układowi nazwę X, ale ta nazwa nie ma
żadnego szczególnego znaczenia.
Moglibyśmy użyć innej
nazwy, gdybyśmy wolelibyśmy, ale żeby jakoś to nazwać,
będziemy nazywać ten układ X.
Przyjmiemy pewne założenie o X, mianowicie że istnieje
skończony zbiór stanów klasycznych, w których X może się
znajdować w dowolnym momencie.
Mówiąc o stanie klasycznym, mam na myśli konfigurację układu, którą można rozpoznać i
opisać jednoznacznie
bez żadnej niepewności czy błędu.
To jest coś, o czym możesz myśleć intuicyjnie. Na poziomie matematycznym po prostu definiujemy
zbiór stanów klasycznych,
wybieramy go tak, jak chcemy, lub w sposób, który najlepiej
opisuje urządzenie, z którym pracujemy.
Nadajmy nazwę sigma
temu zbiorowi stanów klasycznych i ponownie podkreślmy,
że zakładamy, że sigma jest zbiorem skończonym.
Zbiór stanów klasycznych
tego układu X nie jest nieskończenie duży jak
zbiór wszystkich liczb naturalnych.
Jest skończony i takie właśnie
jest nasze założenie.
Na przykład X może być bitem, w takim przypadku zbiór stanów klasycznych to zbiór zawierający dwa
elementy: zero i jeden.
Czasem nazywamy ten
zbiór alfabetem binarnym.
Innym przykładem jest to, że X jest
zwykłą kostką sześcienną, w takim przypadku stanami klasycznymi są liczby od jeden do sześciu.
Oczywiście mówimy tutaj
o abstrakcji.
Rzeczywista kostka sześcienna może
mieć wiele różnych atrybutów, takich jak dokładna
pozycja, orientacja,
temperatura i tak dalej. Ale w odniesieniu do informacji, która jest zazwyczaj istotna, gdy mówimy o kostce sześciennej,
stanami klasycznymi są
liczby od jeden do sześciu wskazywane przez liczbę kropek na tej stronie kostki, która jest skierowana ku górze.
Jeśli X jest przełącznikiem
standardowego wentylatora elektrycznego, jaki możesz mieć w domu, to stanami klasycznymi mogą być
ustawienia: wysoko,
średnio, nisko i wyłączone.
To tylko przykłady. Możemy sobie wyobrazić układy o różnych zbiorach stanów
klasycznych, ale mam nadzieję, że oddają one ideę
że pojęcie stanu klasycznego jest czymś, co powinno być
znajome i można je rozumieć w prostych i intuicyjnych kategoriach.
Matematycznie rzecz biorąc, zbiór stanów klasycznych
jest po prostu zbiorem skończonym, który oczywiście musi
być też niepusty.
Musi istnieć co najmniej
jeden stan klasyczny, w którym układ może się znaleźć, i muszą być co najmniej dwa stany klasyczne,
jeśli układ ma być w ogóle użyteczny do przechowywania informacji.
W niektórych sytuacjach możemy wiedzieć, że X
jest w pewnym konkretnym stanie, ale w wielu sytuacjach,
pojawiających się w kontekście
przetwarzania informacji, może istnieć niepewność co do stanu klasycznego układu w danym momencie,
tak że każdy możliwy stan klasyczny ma pewne powiązane z nim prawdopodobieństwo.
Na przykład, jeśli X jest bitem, to może być tak, że X jest w stanie klasycznym zero
z prawdopodobieństwem trzy czwarte, a jest w stanie jeden
z prawdopodobieństwem jedna czwarta.
Będziemy to nazywać
stanem probabilistycznym, i możemy wyrazić
ten stan probabilistyczny, jak widzisz tutaj,
po prostu wskazując, jakie
są prawdopodobieństwa dla różnych stanów klasycznych.
Bardziej zwięzłym sposobem wyrażenia
tego stanu probabilistycznego jest wektor, a konkretnie reprezentacja,
którą widzisz tutaj,
jest wektorem kolumnowym, który wskazuje
jakie są prawdopodobieństwa dla dwóch możliwych stanów klasycznych.
Mówiąc dokładniej, pierwszy element wskazuje
jakie jest prawdopodobieństwo, że X będzie w stanie zero, a drugi element mówi
nam jakie jest prawdopodobieństwo,
że układ będzie w stanie jeden. To jest po prostu naturalny sposób porządkowania alfabetu binarnego,
a przynajmniej tak
nas uczono to robić. Z zerem na pierwszym miejscu i jedynką na drugim.
W dalszej części będziemy używać
terminu wektor prawdopodobieństwa, by wskazywać wektor tego rodzaju.
WEBVTT
Konkretnie, jest to wektor, którego elementy są wszystkie
nieujemnymi liczbami rzeczywistymi i gdzie suma
elementów jest równa jeden,
więc sensowne jest myślenie
o tych elementach jako o prawdopodobieństwach.
W tym przykładzie są tylko dwa elementy, bo istnieją tylko dwa
stany klasyczne omawianego układu,
ale ogólnie może być
dowolna liczba elementów, z zastrzeżeniem,
że jest jeden element dla każdego stanu klasycznego
jakiegokolwiek układu omawiamy.
Za chwilę będziemy
dalej omawiać informację klasyczną, wektory prawdopodobieństwa i
tak dalej, ale najpierw naprawdę pomocne będzie
wprowadzenie pewnej notacji
do opisu wektorów, zwanej notacją Diraca.
W rzeczywistości jest to tylko pierwsza
część notacji Diraca.
Istnieje kilka innych
aspektów notacji Diraca, które zobaczymy trochę
później w lekcji.
Ta notacja będzie
bardzo ważna dla sposobu, w jaki opisujemy informację kwantową, więc niezbędne jest
zrozumienie, jak działa,
ale na szczęście jest bardzo prosta i tak naprawdę nie ma
nic konkretnie wspólnego z informacją kwantową,
więc możemy ją wprowadzić teraz
w znajomym kontekście informacji klasycznej.
Jak poprzednio, zakładamy, że mamy zbiór sigma
stanów klasycznych pewnego układu, i załóżmy,
że mamy pewne uporządkowanie
tych stanów klasycznych, tak jak odnosiliśmy się do
porządkowania alfabetu binarnego
w poprzednim przykładzie. Inny sposób powiedzenia tego
jest taki, że elementy sigmy są ustawiane w korespondencji
z liczbami całkowitymi
od jeden do jednak wielu
elementów zawiera sigma, co oznacza ta notacja z dwoma kreskami wokół sigmy.
To jest liczba
elementów w zbiorze sigma.
Zatem jest stan pierwszy,
stan drugi i tak dalej.
Konkretne porządkowanie lub
korespondencja, którą wybierzemy, nie będzie tak naprawdę bardzo ważna.
Naprawdę ważne jest
to, że mamy porządkowanie i się go trzymamy.
W przypadku wielu zbiorów stanów
klasycznych, które napotkamy, będzie istniało standardowe porządkowanie, tak jak mamy z
alfabetem binarnym,
a jeśli nie ma standardowego porządkowania, możemy po prostu wybrać jedno.
Ale cokolwiek to jest, przyjmujemy, że się go trzymamy.
Oto notacja,
którą teraz wprowadzamy.
Dla dowolnego wyboru stanu klasycznego
a z naszego zbioru sigma, piszemy to, co widzisz tutaj, co czyta się jako ket a,
i oznacza wektor kolumnowy
mający jedynkę w elemencie odpowiadającym a i zera we wszystkich pozostałych elementach.
Na przykład, wracając
do alfabetu binarnego, który, jak może się domyślasz, jest bardzo ważnym przykładem
do którego będziemy wracać znowu i znowu. Wtedy ket zero i ket jeden to wektory zdefiniowane tutaj.
Ket zero to wektor
mający jedynkę w elemencie odpowiadającym stanowi klasycznemu zero, czyli w pierwszym elemencie,
i zero we wszystkich pozostałych elementach, a w tym przypadku jest
tylko jeden pozostały element.
Podobnie, ket jeden to
ten wektor tutaj, gdzie mamy jedynkę w
elemencie odpowiadającym jeden,
czyli w drugim elemencie, i zero we wszystkich pozostałych elementach, co znowu jest tylko jednym elementem.
Oto kolejny przykład. W tym przykładzie mamy zbiór stanów klasycznych sigma odpowiadający czterem kolorom
w standardowej talii kart do gry: trefl, karo, kier i pik.
W tym przypadku nie ma naprawdę
powszechnie uzgodnionego porządkowania tych kolorów.
W wielu grach karciaryjnych nie ma żadnego porządkowania. To po prostu cztery różne kolory i tyle, i istnieją różne gry
karcianie, które porządkują te kolory
na różne sposoby, ale to nie ma znaczenia.
Możemy po prostu wybrać
porządkowanie takie jak to, które widzisz tutaj.
To jest kolejność alfabetyczna według nazw tych czterech kolorów zapisanych po angielsku,
zakładając, że wybraliśmy
to konkretne porządkowanie, definiujemy te cztery wektory: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts i ket spades
jak widzisz tutaj, i te wektory odpowiadają
ogólnemu opisowi, który widzisz tutaj.
Biorąc pod uwagę, że wybraliśmy
to konkretne porządkowanie dla tych czterech kolorów.
Możemy zrobić to samo dla dowolnego wybranego zbioru stanów klasycznych.
Mając na uwadze, że zbiór stanów
klasycznych zawsze oznacza zbiór skończony i niepusty.
Wektory tej postaci
nazywane są wektorami bazy standardowej i jest to bardzo podstawowy fakt o wektorach, że każdy wektor może być
wyrażony w unikalny sposób
jako liniowa kombinacja
wektorów bazy standardowej.
Na przykład, wracając do przykładu sprzed chwili, wektor prawdopodobieństwa,
który widzieliśmy, można wyrazić
tak jak widzisz tutaj. To zasadniczo tylko alternatywny sposób wyrażania wektorów,
który będzie bardzo przydatny z kilku powodów w przyszłości.
WEBVTT
Mając teraz tę notację w naszych rękach, wróćmy do dyskusji
na temat informacji klasycznej, a w szczególności stanów probabilistycznych.
Zastanówmy się, co się dzieje,
gdy mierzymy układ, gdy jest w pewnym stanie probabilistycznym.
Na co dzień niekoniecznie
mówilibyśmy o pomiarze lub akcie mierzenia
czegoś w kontekście klasycznym, ale ten termin ma sens.
W istocie, gdy mówimy
o mierzeniu układu X w tym kontekście, mamy po prostu na myśli to, że na niego patrzymy i rozpoznajemy, w jakim jest stanie.
Oczywiście, gdy patrzymy na układ, nie widzimy stanu probabilistycznego, widzimy stan klasyczny,
a konkretny
stan klasyczny, który widzimy, to taki, który możemy sobie wyobrazić jako wybrany losowo zgodnie z prawdopodobieństwami.
Możesz mieć filozoficzne zastrzeżenia co do
idei, że stan klasyczny, który widzimy, jest w jakiś sposób wybierany losowo
w momencie, gdy mierzymy lub patrzymy na układ — układ po prostu był w pewnym konkretnym
stanie klasycznym przez cały czas
i po prostu dowiedzieliśmy się,
jaki był ten stan, ale dla celów myślenia o matematycznych
ramach, z którymi pracujemy,
można o tym myśleć w ten sposób, co pozwoli nam narysować analogię z
informacją kwantową trochę później.
Przyjmijmy, że
widzimy stan klasyczny a, który może być dowolnym stanem w naszym zbiorze sigma.
To zmienia stan probabilistyczny
X ogólnie, przynajmniej z naszego punktu widzenia.
Prawdopodobieństwa nie mają już
żadnego znaczenia, ponieważ teraz wiemy, jaki jest
stan klasyczny X.
To a, i nie ma już
żadnej niepewności w tej kwestii.
Powiedzielibyśmy teraz, że
prawdopodobieństwo, że układ jest w stanie a, wynosi jeden.
Wiemy to, bo właśnie na niego spojrzeliśmy i zobaczyliśmy, że stanem klasycznym jest a, więc nowy stan probabilistyczny X to jeden
przy czym prawdopodobieństwo
bycia w stanie klasycznym a jest równe jeden.
A ten stan probabilistyczny jest reprezentowany przez
wektor prawdopodobieństwa ket a.
Mamy jedynkę w elemencie odpowiadającym stanowi klasycznemu a i zero we wszystkich pozostałych elementach.
Na przykład, jeśli ponownie
rozważamy sytuację, w której X jest bitem i mamy ten sam
stan probabilistyczny co przed,
to mierząc X, możemy sobie wyobrazić, że
zachodzi przejście.
Z prawdopodobieństwem trzy czwarte widzimy stan klasyczny zero, a mierząc, przechodzimy do ket zero
jako naszego stanu probabilistycznego,
a z prawdopodobieństwem jedna czwarta przechodzimy do ket jeden.
Możesz myśleć o tym jako o przejściu wiedzy, jeśli wolisz, w przeciwieństwie do rzeczywistego
fizycznego przejścia,
ale co ważne
dla tej lekcji, to rozpoznanie, jak działa matematyka.
To jest właściwie banalne, ale rozpoznając tę banalność, analogiczny opis
dla przypadku kwantowego
może wydawać się trochę mniej tajemniczy.
Ostatnia uwaga jest taka, że dla innej osoby, która nie widziała, jaki
był stan klasyczny X, gdy go mierzyliśmy,
stan probabilistyczny
naturalnie nie zmieniłby się w wyniku naszego pomiaru.
To jest w porządku. Różne osoby mogą
mieć różną wiedzę o danym układzie i odpowiednio wybierać
różne stany probabilistyczne
do reprezentowania swojej
wiedzy o tym układzie.
W ostatniej części tej dyskusji o informacji klasycznej porozmawiamy o klasycznych operacjach, które można wykonywać na układzie,
zaczynając od operacji deterministycznych.
Gdy wykonujemy operację na układzie, jego stan zazwyczaj się zmienia, a w tym kontekście słowo deterministyczny oznacza
że wynik wykonania
operacji zależy całkowicie od tego, w jakim stanie klasycznym był układ
przed wykonaniem operacji.
Innymi słowy, gdy wykonywana jest operacja deterministyczna,
nie ma elementu przypadku, więc nie ma losowości
ani niepewności.
W terminach matematycznych operacje deterministyczne
są opisane przez funkcje.
Każda funkcja f postaci,
którą widzisz tutaj, co oznacza, że zarówno wejście, jak i wyjście funkcji
odpowiadają elementom
naszego zbioru stanów klasycznych sigma, opisuje operację deterministyczną.
Stan klasyczny a jest
przekształcany w stan f z a dla każdego wyboru stanu a.
Dla każdej funkcji f tej postaci zawsze istnieje unikalna macierz M spełniająca ten warunek,
który widzisz tutaj,
mianowicie że mnożąc
M przez wektor ket a daje nam wektor ket f z a,
i to jest prawdziwe dla każdego
wyboru stanu klasycznego a.
Niezbyt trudno jest zapisać
jawny opis M dla dowolnej wybranej funkcji f
tej postaci.
Zawsze będzie miała dokładnie
jedną jedynkę w każdej kolumnie, a wszystkie pozostałe elementy równe zero.
A oto wzór. Element b, a macierzy M jest równy jeden, jeśli b jest równe f z a
a w przeciwnym razie jest równy zero, i przez to rozumiemy,
że jest to element M, którego wiersz odpowiada b
a kolumna odpowiada a.
WEBVTT
Za chwilę zobaczymy kilka przykładów i dowiemy się, dlaczego ten wzór działa.
Może nie być jasne, dlaczego chcielibyśmy wziąć funkcję i wyrazić ją jako macierz,
ale ma to sens. Jednym z powodów, a może jest to główny powód, jest to, że jeśli mamy układ
w stanie probabilistycznym
i wykonujemy deterministyczną
operację na tym układzie, to wynikowy stan probabilistyczny
można uzyskać
przez mnożenie macierzy przez wektor, tzn. jeśli nasz układ jest
w stanie probabilistycznym
reprezentowanym przez
pewien wektor prawdopodobieństwa v i wykonujemy deterministyczną
operację opisaną przez M
na tym układzie, to wynikowy stan probabilistyczny będzie dany przez M razy v.
Nawiasem mówiąc, ta strzałka z małą kreseczką
jest po prostu powszechną notacją matematyczną oznaczającą, jak jedna
rzecz jest przekształcana
lub zamieniana w inną. Można by użyć zwykłej strzałki, ale ta jest konwencjonalna
i rozpoznawalna, i może jest trochę bardziej precyzyjna niż po prostu strzałka, która może oznaczać wiele różnych rzeczy.
Teraz przyjrzyjmy się przykładowi, a właściwie zbiorowi przykładów.
Rozważmy co się dzieje, gdy weźmiemy nasz zbiór stanów klasycznych sigma jako znowu alfabet binarny.
Nie ma zbyt wielu różnych funkcji postaci, którą omawialiśmy, gdy to jest nasz zbiór stanów klasycznych, i mówiąc dokładniej, istnieją tylko cztery
funkcje tej postaci.
Oto te cztery funkcje opisane przez tak zwane tablice wartości.
Pierwsza tablica opisuje
pierwszą funkcję, którą nazwaliśmy f1.
Dla każdego możliwego wejścia po lewej, wypisujemy odpowiednie
wyjście po prawej, więc f1 z zero jest równe zero,
a f1 z jeden jest, ponownie, równe zero, co oznacza, że f1 jest
funkcją stale równą zero.
Zawsze przyjmuje wartość zero.
Druga funkcja f2
jest funkcją identycznościową.
Wyjście jest zawsze równe wejściu, co widać z drugiej tablicy.
Trzecia funkcja f3 jest
opisana przez trzecią tablicę.
f3 z zero jest równe jeden, a f3 z jeden jest równe zero.
Ta funkcja jest lepiej
znana jako funkcja NOT lub negacja logiczna.
Czasem nazywamy ją też przerzutnikiem bitu, ponieważ odwraca zero
na jeden i jeden na zero.
Ostatnia funkcja f4 jest
znowu funkcją stałą, tak jak pierwsza, ale ta jest funkcją stale równą jeden,
ponieważ zawsze przyjmuje wartość jeden.
I to są wszystkie cztery funkcje z alfabetu binarnego w siebie.
Oto cztery macierze odpowiadające tym czterem funkcjom, opisane przez
wzór z poprzedniego,
który widzisz tutaj, i jeśli masz ochotę, możesz zatrzymać wideo i to sprawdzić.
Pamiętaj tylko, że w macierzach kolejność indeksów to zawsze najpierw wiersze, potem kolumny.
Więc element b, a odpowiada
wierszowi b i kolumnie a lub wierszowi odpowiadającemu
stanowi klasycznemu b
i kolumnie odpowiadającej
stanowi klasycznemu a.
Na przykład, jeśli spojrzymy
na pierwszą funkcję, mamy f1 z zero równe zero
i odpowiednio element
zero, zero macierzy M1 jest równy jeden.
A element jeden, zero,
który jest tutaj, jest równy zero, i to samo możesz zrobić dla przypadku
gdy wejście jest równe jeden, i podobnie dla
pozostałych trzech funkcji.
Możesz też sprawdzić, że
wzór z poprzedniego jest prawdziwy, i możesz po kolei przejrzeć wszystkie różne
możliwości, żeby to zweryfikować.
I właściwie, jeśli pomyślisz o tym, jak
działa mnożenie macierzy, możesz to w zasadzie ocenić wzrokowo.
Gdy mnożysz macierz przez wektor bazy standardowej, możesz sobie wyobrazić, że
bierzesz wejście
i wkładasz je na górę jednej z macierzy w tej kolumnie, która odpowiada stanowi klasycznemu
wewnątrz ket, a wyjście, które
otrzymujesz, to po prostu ta kolumna jako wektor prawdopodobieństwa.
Na przykład M3 pomnożone przez ket
zero daje zero, jeden
jako wektor prawdopodobieństwa, czyli ket jeden.
M3 pomnożone przez ket
jeden daje jeden, zero, czyli ket zero i tak dalej.
Omówimy operacje na
stanach probabilistycznych za chwilę, ale najpierw wprowadźmy drugą część notacji Diraca.
Będzie to pomocne
do mówienia o operacjach i myślenia o nich jako o macierzach, i będzie to też standardowe narzędzie
którego będziemy dalej używać. Konfiguracja jest taka sama jak poprzednio.
Mamy dowolny zbiór stanów klasycznych sigma, z którym pracujemy, i zakładamy, że mamy pewien sposób
porządkowania tych stanów klasycznych.
Następnie piszemy tę rzecz,
którą widzisz tutaj, gdzie tym razem nawiasowy pasek jest po lewej, a nie po prawej, aby oznaczać wektor wierszowy mający jedynkę
w elemencie odpowiadającym
a i zero we wszystkich pozostałych elementach odpowiadających wszystkim
innym stanom klasycznym.
Różnica między
tą rzeczą a ket a jest taka, że ta jest wektorem wierszowym, a
ket a jest wektorem kolumnowym,
WEBVTT
ale poza tym wektory
są zdefiniowane w podobny sposób.
Czytamy to jako bra a; nie wiem, czy to ma być śmieszne, ale chodzi o to, że nazwy bra i ket
są dwiema połówkami słowa bracket (nawias), i powiemy o tym więcej
za chwilę.
Ale najpierw przyjrzyjmy się
bardzo szybkiemu przykładowi.
Dla alfabetu binarnego mamy, że bra zero to
ten wektor wierszowy analogiczny do ket a,
z tym że jest wektorem wierszowym
zamiast kolumnowego, a bra jeden to ten wektor tutaj.
Ogólnie, jeśli mnożymy wektor
wierszowy przez wektor kolumnowy, myśląc o nich jako o macierzach
mających po prostu
jeden wiersz lub jedną kolumnę, to otrzymujemy macierz jeden na jeden, którą możemy traktować
jako skalar.
Nawiasem mówiąc, powinieneś/-aś
myśleć o tych gwiazdkach jako reprezentujących dowolne liczby.
W szczególności, jeśli
mnożymy wektor wierszowy bra a przez wektor kolumnowy ket b,
to mogą zajść dwie rzeczy.
Jedna jest taka, że a i b są równe, czyli są tym samym stanem klasycznym, w takim przypadku jedynki się pokryją
i iloczyn będzie równy jeden, albo może być tak,
że a i b są różne,
więc jedynki się nie pokrywają i iloczyn jest równy zero.
Prosty sposób wyrażenia
tych obserwacji to właśnie to, co widzisz tutaj.
I żeby zachować porządek, piszemy ten iloczyn tak, z tylko jedną kreseczką w środku, i oznacza to dokładnie to samo
co to tutaj.
I teraz możesz zobaczyć, jak
bra i ket łączą się tworząc bracket (nawias), który
jest też nazywany iloczynem skalarnym,
i to jest coś
dość ważnego, do czego wrócimy
w lekcji trzeciej.
Mnożenie wektora
kolumnowego przez wektor wierszowy z drugiej strony daje nam macierz, jak widzisz tutaj.
Na przykład, wracając po raz kolejny
do alfabetu binarnego, jeśli mnożymy ket zero przez bra zero,
otrzymujemy tę macierz tutaj, i możemy przejrzeć
pozostałe możliwości, żeby zobaczyć, co się dzieje.
Ket zero razy bra jeden daje
nam tę macierz tutaj, gdzie jedynka przesunęła się
na tę pozycję.
Ket jeden razy bra zero wygląda tak, a oto ket jeden razy bra jeden.
Widzimy, że jest tylko jedna jedynka w macierzy, która poza tym składa się z samych zer, a pozycja tej jedynki
jest wyznaczona przez to, jakie
stany klasyczne wybieramy w bra i w ket.
Mówiąc dokładniej, i jest to prawda ogólnie, dla dowolnego zbioru stanów klasycznych, macierz, którą otrzymujemy przez
mnożenie ket a przez bra b
jest macierzą z jedynką na pozycji a, b i zerami we wszystkich pozostałych elementach.
I teraz, mając zarówno
pierwszą, jak i drugą część notacji Diraca, mamy bardzo przydatne narzędzie do łączenia operacji z macierzami.
Wróćmy więc krótko
do operacji deterministycznych i przypomnijmy, że wcześniej w lekcji
stwierdzono, że dla każdej funkcji f
tej postaci tutaj, mamy operację deterministyczną przekształcającą a w f z a
dla każdego możliwego stanu klasycznego a. Powiedzieliśmy, że dla
każdej takiej funkcji zawsze istnieje unikalna
macierz M działająca tak
na stanach bazy standardowej.
Używając notacji Diraca, możemy teraz bardzo łatwo wyrazić tę macierz jak widzisz tutaj,
i widzimy, jak czasami
jest możliwe pracowanie z macierzami całkowicie
w ramach notacji Diraca
bez jawnego przeliczania
na wektory i macierze, czyli prostokąty wypełnione liczbami.
W tym przypadku możemy sprawdzić, że
wymagany wzór jest prawdziwy, mnożąc M przez ket a.
Podstawiamy nasze
wyrażenie na M i możemy usunąć nawiasy i złożyć razem bra
b z ket a.
Dzieje się tak, ponieważ mnożenie macierzy
jest liniowe, w tym przypadku względem pierwszego argumentu, i jest łączne, więc możemy usunąć nawiasy.
I teraz, przypominając, że mamy ustalone a, o którym mówimy, sumując po wszystkich
możliwych wyborach b,
ten bracket tutaj będzie
zawsze równy zero, gdy b nie jest równe a, więc nie będzie żadnego
wkładu do sumy,
a gdy b jest równe a, bracket będzie równy jeden i pozostanie nam
ten jeden wyraz tutaj.
To jest wzór, którego chcieliśmy, i mamy bardzo ładny i prosty sposób wyrażania funkcji jako macierzy.
Oprócz operacji deterministycznych, mamy też operacje, które
same wprowadzają losowość lub niepewność co do
stanu klasycznego układu.
Używamy terminu operacja probabilistyczna, by oznaczać operacje tego rodzaju, i mówiąc precyzyjnie, gdy mówimy operacja probabilistyczna,
mamy na myśli operacje, które
mogą wprowadzać losowość, więc operacje deterministyczne są właściwie szczególnym przypadkiem
operacji probabilistycznych,
które po prostu nie
wprowadzają żadnej losowości.
Oto prosty przykład, gdzie
wprowadzana jest pewna losowość.
Jest to operacja na pojedynczym bicie. Działa w ten sposób, że jeśli stan klasyczny
bitu wynosi zero,
to nic się nie dzieje. Bit pozostaje zerem, ale jeśli stan klasyczny
bitu wynosi jeden, to operacja przerzuca bit na zero
WEBVTT
z prawdopodobieństwem równym 1/2.
Nie ma specjalnej nazwy
dla tej operacji, przynajmniej nie takiej, o której wiem.
To tylko przykład, ale możesz sobie wyobrazić wykonywanie
tej operacji na bicie.
Tak jak operacje deterministyczne, operacje probabilistyczne mogą
być reprezentowane przez macierze, a ich działanie na stanach probabilistycznych
jest dane przez mnożenie macierzy przez wektor, tak samo jak poprzednio.
Tym razem niekoniecznie jest tak, że macierze mają dokładnie jedną jedynkę w każdej kolumnie i zera w pozostałych.
Operacje probabilistyczne są
ogólniej reprezentowane przez macierze stochastyczne.
Są to macierze, których elementy są wszystkie
nieujemnymi liczbami rzeczywistymi i gdzie elementy w
każdej kolumnie sumują się do jeden.
To jest równoważne powiedzeniu,
że macierze stochastyczne to macierze, gdzie każda kolumna
tworzy wektor prawdopodobieństwa.
Ma to sens, gdy myślisz o
działaniu macierzy na wektorze bazy standardowej.
Bierzesz dowolny
stan klasyczny i wyobrażasz sobie, że wkładasz go na górę macierzy w tej kolumnie, która odpowiada
temu stanowi klasycznemu,
a ta kolumna mówi ci, jaki jest
stan probabilistyczny, który wychodzi jako wektor prawdopodobieństwa.
Operacja probabilistyczna
w naszym przykładzie jest opisana przez tę macierz tutaj.
Jeśli wykonamy tę operację
na stanie klasycznym zero, to stan probabilistyczny, który otrzymujemy, jest dany przez pierwszą kolumnę,
czyli ponownie stan klasyczny zero lub równoważnie stan probabilistyczny,
gdzie zero występuje z prawdopodobieństwem jeden.
Jeśli zamiast tego wykonamy tę operację na stanie klasycznym jeden, to efektywnie po prostu losujemy bit i odpowiednio otrzymujemy
ten wektor prawdopodobieństwa
gdzie prawdopodobieństwo
każdego z możliwych stanów jest równe 1/2.
Ogólnie, jeśli wykonamy tę operację na dowolnym stanie probabilistycznym, to efekt to w zasadzie
ważona średnia między dwiema kolumnami
bo tak działa
mnożenie macierzy przez wektor.
Jest liniowe, więc po prostu odpowiednio uśredniamy dwa
możliwe wyniki.
Gdy myślimy o operacjach probabilistycznych
w ten sposób, naturalne jest myślenie o
nich jako potencjalnie wprowadzających lub wstrzykujących losowość.
Możemy po prostu czytać kolumny jedną po drugiej i widzieć losowość,
którą wprowadzają dla każdego możliwego stanu klasycznego.
Możesz też myśleć o
operacjach probabilistycznych w nieco inny sposób, mianowicie jako o losowych wyborach operacji deterministycznych.
Na przykład, w naszym przypadku możemy myśleć o tej operacji jako równoważnej
rzutowi monetą
i albo wykonaniu
funkcji stałej zero, albo funkcji identycznościowej,
każda z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2,
i możesz to zobaczyć odzwierciedlone
tutaj przez to równanie.
To jest zawsze możliwe dla
dowolnej operacji probabilistycznej i jest dość intuicyjne.
Jeśli dokonywałeś/-aś losowych wyborów
jako część jakiegoś procesu, zawsze możesz sobie wyobrazić dokonywanie tych losowych wyborów z góry
i zakodowanie tych
wyborów na stałe w pewnym zbiorze operacji deterministycznych.
Czasem jest całkiem pomocne myślenie o operacjach probabilistycznych
w ten sposób, i zobaczymy przykład
tego w następnych kilku lekcjach.
Ostatnia rzecz do powiedzenia
o informacji klasycznej w tej lekcji dotyczy składania
operacji probabilistycznych, co po prostu oznacza wykonywanie
jednej po drugiej.
Załóżmy, że
mamy jakiś układ nazwany X, a M1 do Mn to macierze stochastyczne reprezentujące operacje probabilistyczne
na X.
Wyobraź sobie, że mamy
wektor prawdopodobieństwa v, który reprezentuje stan probabilistyczny
X w pewnym momencie, a potem najpierw stosujemy
pierwszą operację probabilistyczną do X, reprezentowaną przez macierz M1, a potem stosujemy drugą
operację probabilistyczną,
reprezentowaną przez M2.
Jeśli to zrobimy, to
wektor prawdopodobieństwa, który otrzymujemy po zastosowaniu tylko pierwszej
operacji, to M1 razy v,
a gdy stosujemy
drugą operację, wynikowy wektor prawdopodobieństwa to M2 pomnożone przez wektor, który uzyskaliśmy
po zastosowaniu M1. Wygląda to tak.
Mnożenie macierzy
jest operacją łączną, co oznacza, że nie ma znaczenia, gdzie stawiamy te nawiasy.
Możemy więc równie dobrze
postawić nawiasy tak.
To jest bardzo proste, ale jest też interesujące, ponieważ ujawnia, że możemy myśleć o operacji, w której najpierw stosujemy M1
a potem stosujemy M2,
jako o pojedynczej operacji.
Innymi słowy, operacja probabilistyczna, którą otrzymujemy przez składanie pierwszej i
drugiej operacji probabilistycznej, jest reprezentowana przez
iloczyn macierzy M2 razy M1,
i jest to ta sama operacja niezależnie od tego, od jakiego stanu probabilistycznego
zaczęliśmy.
Nie musimy wiedzieć niczego o wektorze prawdopodobieństwa v, żeby myśleć o lub opisywać
tę złożoną operację.
Zauważ, że kolejność
tutaj to M2 po lewej i M1 po prawej, co wynika z tego, że
macierz po prawej, M1,
jest tą, która jest
mnożona przez wektor v, podczas gdy M2 jest mnożone
przez wektor, który otrzymujemy po pomnożeniu przez M1.
WEBVTT
Więc zawsze musimy mieć na uwadze, że kolejność w pewnym sensie
jest odwrócona.
Operacja wykonywana
jako pierwsza jest tą po prawej, a operacja wykonywana jako ostatnia, lub w tym przypadku druga,
jest tą po lewej.
Jeśli nie zatrzymujemy się na drugiej operacji i stosujemy je wszystkie po kolei, zaczynając od pierwszej i kończąc na ostatniej, czyli Mn,
to złożenie wszystkich
tych operacji razem jest dane przez ten iloczyn,
który widzisz tutaj,
i widzisz, że kolejność
jest ponownie odwrócona dokładnie z tego samego powodu co poprzednio.
Krótko mówiąc, złożenia
operacji probabilistycznych są reprezentowane przez iloczyny
macierzy stochastycznych, które je reprezentują.
Mając na uwadze, że to jest
kolejność macierzy w iloczynie.
Mnożąc macierze stochastyczne w ten sposób zawsze otrzymasz macierz stochastyczną, i czasem wyrażamy ten fakt
mówiąc, że macierze
stochastyczne są domknięte ze względu na mnożenie, i możesz o tym myśleć tak, że nie można wyjść poza
zbiór macierzy stochastycznych
przez ich mnożenie, ponieważ zbiór jest domknięty.
Wracając do
kolejności macierzy w tym iloczynie, ważne jest, by zauważyć, że kolejność naprawdę ma znaczenie.
Mnożenie macierzy nie jest przemienne. Jeśli zmienisz kolejność
macierzy w iloczynie, możesz zmienić wynik,
i nie musimy szukać dalej niż operacje deterministyczne,
żeby to zobaczyć.
Oto prosty przykład
dwóch macierzy stochastycznych, obie reprezentują
operacje deterministyczne, gdzie kolejność ma znaczenie.
M1 reprezentuje funkcję stałą zero. Zakładamy, że wyobrażamy sobie te dwie operacje jako operacje na bitach, tak jak w przykładzie z poprzedniego.
M2 reprezentuje operację NOT
lub przerzutnik bitu.
Jeśli najpierw wykonasz M1
a potem M2, wynikiem jest ta macierz tutaj, która reprezentuje
funkcję stałą jeden.
Jeśli ustawisz bit na zero
a potem go przerzucisz, to jest to to samo co po prostu
ustawienie tego bitu na jeden.
Z drugiej strony, jeśli najpierw wykonasz M2
a potem M1, wynik jest taki tutaj,
i ma to sens, ponieważ jeśli przerzucisz bit
a potem ustawisz go na zero, to jest to to samo co
po prostu ustawienie go na zero.
Nie miało znaczenia, że go przerzuciłeś/-aś. Oczywiście te dwie
macierze nie są takie same, i mamy bardzo
prosty przykład ujawniający
że kolejność ma znaczenie. Oczywiście nie jest to zaskakujące.
Wszyscy wiemy, że kolejność, w jakiej
operacje są wykonywane, ma znaczenie, albo przynajmniej może mieć znaczenie.
Na przykład, jeśli zapalasz
zapałkę a potem na nią dmuchasz, wynik jest bardzo różny
od dmuchania na zapałkę najpierw
a potem jej zapalania. W tym momencie powiedzieliśmy całkiem dużo
o informacji klasycznej i nadszedł w końcu czas, żeby
omówić informację kwantową.
A odkryjemy, że
matematycznie rzecz biorąc, informacja kwantowa działa
bardzo podobnie do informacji klasycznej
z pewnymi kluczowymi różnicami.
Pierwsza kluczowa różnica
jest na samym początku: jak definiujemy stan, w tym przypadku stan kwantowy układu,
i jest pewien sens, w którym ten jeden wybór — jak
definiujemy stan kwantowy — w dużej mierze wyznacza, jak
działa informacja kwantowa.
Zdefiniujemy też, jak
działają pomiary i operacje, a w następnej lekcji omówimy, jak
informacja kwantowa działa nie tylko dla pojedynczych układów,
ale dla wielu układów,
ale te rzeczy wynikają
dość naturalnie, gdy pojęcie stanu kwantowego pojedynczego układu w
izolacji zostało ustalone.
Oto definicja. Stan kwantowy układu jest reprezentowany przez wektor kolumnowy, którego indeksy są ustawione
w korespondencji ze stanami
klasycznymi tego układu.
Zakładamy więc tutaj, że
układ, o którym mówimy, ma pewien zbiór stanów klasycznych, tak jak gdy mówiliśmy
o informacji klasycznej
i stanach probabilistycznych. Elementy wektora stanu kwantowego
są liczbami zespolonymi, w odróżnieniu od przypadku probabilistycznego
gdzie elementy są
nieujemnymi liczbami rzeczywistymi.
I tym razem suma kwadratów wartości bezwzględnych
elementów musi być równa jeden, w odróżnieniu od sumy równej jeden,
jaką mamy w przypadku probabilistycznym.
Liczby zespolone pojawiające się
w wektorze stanu kwantowego są czasem nazywane amplitudami i pełnią rolę podobną do prawdopodobieństw,
ale nie są prawdopodobieństwami i nie mają tej
samej interpretacji.
Nie mogę podać dobrego powodu, dlaczego stany kwantowe
powinny być zdefiniowane w ten sposób, poza stwierdzeniem, że
fizycy odkryli,
że ta definicja
jest fizycznie istotna i pozwala nam opisywać i modelować
układy mechaniki kwantowej.
Innymi słowy, wybieramy tę definicję,
ponieważ działa, a nie dlatego, że istnieją
jakiekolwiek szczególne powody, dla których stany kwantowe powinny
być zdefiniowane w ten sposób.
Jeśli chodzi o
matematykę tego pojęcia stanu kwantowego, pierwszym krokiem do jego zrozumienia i pracy z nim jest
przypomnienie tej definicji
normy euklidesowej wektora, którą możesz geometrycznie myśleć jako długość wektora, tak jak myślałbyś/-abyś o długości
dwuwymiarowego wektora rzeczywistego, gdybyś narysował/-a go na kartce papieru jako strzałkę zaczynającą się od początku układu współrzędnych w zwykły sposób.
WEBVTT
Konkretnie, jeśli mamy
wektor kolumnowy v, który zakładamy ma
elementy będące liczbami zespolonymi, alfa jeden do alfa n,
to norma euklidesowa v jest zdefiniowana tak, jak widzisz tutaj.
To jest notacja, której
używamy dla normy euklidesowej, stawiając te podwójne kreski wokół wektora, o którym mówimy.
W tym przypadku jest to v, a norma euklidesowa jest zdefiniowana jako pierwiastek kwadratowy z sumy
kwadratów wartości bezwzględnych
elementów wektora.
Innym sposobem zdefiniowania czym jest
wektor stanu kwantowego jest to, że wektor stanu kwantowego to wektor kolumnowy mający
elementy będące liczbami zespolonymi
którego norma euklidesowa jest równa jeden, co oznacza, że jest to wektor jednostkowy względem normy euklidesowej.
Dzieje się tak, ponieważ suma
kwadratów wartości bezwzględnych jest równa jeden wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy norma euklidesowa
jest równa jeden.
Pierwiastek kwadratowy niczego nie zmienia, gdy suma kwadratów wartości
bezwzględnych jest równa jeden.
Taki więc jest wektor stanu kwantowego. To wektor kolumnowy z indeksami odpowiadającymi stanom klasycznym układu
mający elementy będące liczbami zespolonymi i normę euklidesową równą jeden.
Co to oznacza, co z tego wynika lub jak powinniśmy interpretować to
pojęcie, to inna kwestia, i w pewnym sensie,
badanie informacji
i obliczeń kwantowych to eksploracja tego, co
ta definicja implikuje, przynajmniej w kategoriach
przetwarzania informacji.
To jest po prostu punkt wyjścia.
Przy okazji, wspomnę, że istnieją
inne tzw. normy oprócz normy euklidesowej, i ta notacja z podwójnymi kreskami
wokół wektora nie zawsze
oznacza normę euklidesową.
W różnych kontekstach ta notacja może odnosić się
do innej normy.
Na przykład, suma
wartości bezwzględnych bez potęgowania ani pierwiastka kwadratowego to inna norma,
często nazywana normą jeden. Istnieje całkiem sporo
różnych norm.
Czasem zobaczysz
tę notację używaną z indeksem dolnym po
drugiej parze kresek, który podaje więcej informacji o tym, o jakiej normie mówimy.
Kiedy to robimy, typowe jest to, że liczba dwa jako indeks dolny
oznacza normę euklidesową.
Ale w tej serii, gdy mamy
wektor kolumnowy, ta notacja z podwójnymi kreskami sama w sobie
oznacza normę euklidesową.
Oto kilka przykładów
wektorów stanu kwantowego, a te konkretne wektory stanu kwantowego to wektory stanu qubit,
co oznacza, że
stany klasyczne naszego układu to zero i jeden.
Słowo qubit pochodzi od quantum bit, co jest po prostu bitem,
który może być w stanie kwantowym.
Pierwsze dwa przykłady są naprawdę proste. Wektory bazy standardowej
ket zero i ket jeden to wektory stanu kwantowego.
Oba są wektorami kolumnowymi, i indeksy odpowiadają
stanom klasycznym zero i jeden, a elementy tych
wektorów są liczbami zespolonymi.
Dla tych konkretnych wektorów elementy to zero i jeden, które są liczbami rzeczywistymi, a właściwie liczbami całkowitymi, ale są też liczbami zespolonymi
które mają
część urojoną równą zero.
Każdy wektor ma jeden element równy jeden i jeden element równy zero.
Więc gdy sumujemy kwadraty wartości
bezwzględnych elementów, w obu przypadkach otrzymujemy jeden.
Warunki wymagane, by te wektory były
wektorami stanu kwantowego, są więc spełnione.
Następne dwa przykłady to bardzo często spotykane stany qubit zwane stanem plus i stanem minus.
Są oznaczane tak,
jak widzisz tutaj na ekranie, albo jako ket plus
albo jako ket minus, i są zdefiniowane tak, jak widzisz tutaj.
Ponownie, elementy tych
wektorów są liczbami zespolonymi. Tym razem są to albo dodatnie jeden przez pierwiastek kwadratowy z dwóch, albo ujemne jeden przez pierwiastek kwadratowy z dwóch,
a gdy sumujemy
kwadraty wartości bezwzględnych, otrzymujemy 1/2 plus 1/2, czyli jeden.
Nawiasem mówiąc, stawianie
znaku plus lub minus wewnątrz ket
może wydawać się trochę dziwne, bo to nie są stany klasyczne naszego układu,
ale ta notacja jest mimo to używana, i wrócimy do tego za chwilę.
Ale na razie, krótko mówiąc, możemy używać notacji Diraca, by wstawiać dowolną nazwę dla wektora wewnątrz ket.
Wektor nie musi
być wektorem bazy standardowej, gdy używamy notacji Diraca.
Oto ostatni przykład stanu qubit
na razie.
Jest to wektor stanu kwantowego qubit, który nie ma specjalnej nazwy i nie jest szczególnie istotny.
Elementy tego wektora to jeden plus dwa razy i
podzielone przez trzy i minus 2/3.
Są to liczby zespolone i jeśli obliczysz kwadraty wartości bezwzględnych tych dwóch elementów, otrzymasz 5/9 dla pierwszego
i 4/9 dla drugiego. Suma kwadratów wartości
bezwzględnych jest więc równa jeden.
A oto ostatni przykład. Tym razem dla układu
którego stanami klasycznymi są cztery kolory kart.
Nie wiem, dlaczego mielibyśmy mieć układ, którego stanami klasycznymi
są cztery kolory kart będący w stanie kwantowym, ale jest to możliwe w zasadzie
i jest to po prostu przykład.
WEBVTT
Elementy odpowiadające
różnym kolorom to 1/2 dla trefla, minus
i podzielone przez dwa dla kara,
zero dla kiera, bo nie pojawia się w sumie, i jeden przez pierwiastek
kwadratowy z dwóch dla pika.
A oto jak wygląda to
jako wektor kolumnowy, zakładając, że uporządkowaliśmy
stany klasyczne tak jak poprzednio,
czyli w kolejności,
którą widzisz tutaj.
Kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej
tych elementów daje jedną czwartą dla pierwszego, również jedną czwartą dla następnego.
zera jest równy zero, więc ten element nie
przyczynia się do sumy.
I wreszcie, dla ostatniego, otrzymujemy 1/2. Suma jest więc równa jeden, co jest wymagane, by ten wektor
był wektorem stanu kwantowego.
Przed chwilą użyliśmy notacji
ket plus i ket minus, by odnieść się do dwóch wektorów stanu qubit, które nie są wektorami bazy standardowej.
Chciałbym krótko
wrócić do tego punktu i wyjaśnić, jak notacja Diraca jest używana dla dowolnych wektorów, a nie tylko dla wektorów bazy standardowej.
Jak już wspomniałem, możemy używać dowolnej nazwy, jaką chcemy, wewnątrz bra lub ket, by odnieść się do wektora.
Kety to wektory kolumnowe,
a bry to wektory wierszowe, tak jak poprzednio.
Jako przykład, grecka litera
psi jest bardzo często używana wewnątrz ket, by odnieść się do pewnego dowolnego wektora,
i tutaj używamy jej, by
nadać nazwę wektorowi stanu z poprzedniego, który nie
ma specjalnej nazwy.
Gdy to robimy, litera psi nie
musi mieć żadnego znaczenia sama w sobie.
Jest po prostu nazwą wektora i jest wewnątrz ket, by pomóc nam wyjaśnić,
że jest to wektor kolumnowy.
Może to być czasem
trochę mylące, i istnieje potencjał niejednoznaczności, jeśli litera psi mogłaby być kojarzona
ze stanem klasycznym
jakiegoś układu na przykład, ale generalnie nie sprawia
to żadnych problemów i nie musisz używać
notacji Diraca w ten sposób,
jeśli nie chcesz. Używanie małej litery, np.
u, v lub w bez ket, jest też dobrym sposobem na
oznaczenie wektora kolumnowego
lub dokładniej,
wektora stanu kwantowego.
Twój wybór, jaką notację
używasz do wyrażania się.
Musisz tylko upewnić się, że po pierwsze, znaczenie tego, co
próbujesz wyrazić, jest jasne dla innych.
I po drugie, że rozumiesz, co
inni próbują wyrazić, nawet gdy ich preferencje dotyczące notacji nie są takie same jak twoje.
Istnieje jedna bardzo ważna reguła korzystania z notacji Diraca
dla dowolnych wektorów, a mianowicie: jeśli masz wektor kolumnowy,
który zdecydowałeś/-aś się pisać
jako ket psi, na przykład, lub może inna
nazwa wewnątrz ket, to wektor wierszowy bra psi
jest rozumiany jako
sprzężony transponowany wektora ket psi.
I tutaj jest to zapisane jako równanie, gdzie ten sztylet oznacza sprzężony transponowany.
Konkretnie jest to
wektor wierszowy, który otrzymujesz przez, po pierwsze, transponowanie wektora, co oznacza, że obracasz wektor na bok i zmieniasz go z kolumnowego na wierszowy
bez zmieniania elementów. I po drugie, biorąc sprzężenie zespolone
każdego z elementów.
Możesz właściwie wykonać
te dwie operacje, transponowanie i
elementowe sprzężenie zespolone, w dowolnej kolejności — te
dwie operacje komutują.
Tak więc dla wektora z tego przykładu, biorąc pod uwagę, że zdecydowaliśmy się
nazwać ten wektor ket psi, przyjmuje się, że bra psi
oznacza ten wektor tutaj,
gdzie transponowaliśmy wektor, zamieniając ket zero i ket
jeden na bra zero i bra jeden, i wzięliśmy sprzężenie zespolone każdego elementu,
dlatego jeden plus
dwa razy i podzielone przez trzy zamienia się w jeden minus dwa
razy i podzielone przez trzy tutaj.
Oto jak te wektory wyglądają, gdy są zapisane
jawnie jako wektor kolumnowy i wektor wierszowy.
Zauważ nawiasem mówiąc, że
ta reguła jest zgodna z notacją, której używamy, gdy mamy stany klasyczne
wewnątrz bra i ket.
W takim przypadku elementy są
wszystkie zerowe poza jedną jedynką, i wzięcie sprzężenia
zespolonego niczego nie zmienia w tym przypadku.
Widzieliśmy już, jak stany kwantowe są reprezentowane jako wektory, ale na tym etapie nie jest jasne, jakie jest znaczenie lub implikacje
w kategoriach tego, co
możesz robić z układem w stanie kwantowym lub jak możesz z nim wchodzić w interakcję.
Pierwszą rzeczą, którą musimy zrobić, by skupić te kwestie,
jest omówienie pomiarów.
Intuicyjnie mówiąc,
pomiary zapewniają mechanizm wyodrębniania informacji klasycznej
z układów kwantowych.
Gdy patrzymy na układ,
gdy jest w stanie kwantowym, nie widzimy stanu kwantowego, tak jak nie widzimy
stanów probabilistycznych,
widzimy stany klasyczne, i pojęcie pomiaru jest tym, co zapewnia interfejs.
Jeśli my, jako ludzie, chcemy wiedzieć coś o układzie kwantowym, musimy go zmierzyć, i robiąc to, wyodrębnimy informację klasyczną
o tym, w jakim stanie kwantowym
był ten układ.
Istnieją różne
pojęcia pomiarów. Różnią się ogólnością, i zaczniemy od najprostszego i najbardziej podstawowego,
który jest zazwyczaj nazywany
pomiarem w bazie standardowej.
WEBVTT
Uogólnimy to
w kolejnych lekcjach. Omówimy tzw.
pomiary rzutowe w lekcji trzeciej, a potem później w
trzecim module serii,
omówimy pomiary ogólne, zwane też pozytywnymi miarami operatorowymi lub w skrócie POVM-ami.
Ale na razie ograniczymy naszą uwagę do pomiarów w bazie standardowej.
Gdy wykonywany jest pomiar
na układzie, będzie istniał pewien zbiór
możliwych wyników tego pomiaru, które są wynikami klasycznymi,
a w przypadku pomiaru
w bazie standardowej, te możliwe wyniki są
dokładnie stanami klasycznymi mierzonego układu.
Każdy z tych stanów klasycznych będzie wynikiem pomiaru z pewnym prawdopodobieństwem, a to prawdopodobieństwo to kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej
elementu odpowiadającego
temu stanowi klasycznemu w wektorze stanu kwantowego, w którym układ się znajdował bezpośrednio przed pomiarem.
Wiemy, że kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej dowolnej liczby zespolonej jest nieujemną liczbą rzeczywistą, i wiemy z definicji
wektorów stanu kwantowego,
że suma kwadratów wartości
bezwzględnych elementów wektora stanu kwantowego jest równa jeden.
Ma to więc sens. Każdy stan klasyczny będzie się pojawiał jako wynik pomiaru
z pewnym prawdopodobieństwem, a prawdopodobieństwa sumują się do jeden.
Oto kilka przykładów. Najpierw załóżmy, że mamy
qubit w stanie plus.
Jeśli zmierzymy ten qubit za pomocą pomiaru
w bazie standardowej, otrzymamy albo zero albo
jeden jako wynik.
Prawdopodobieństwo otrzymania zera to kwadrat wartości
bezwzględnej jeden przez pierwiastek z dwóch, co wynosi 1/2, i takie samo jest
prawdopodobieństwo otrzymania jedynki.
Jeśli więc zmierzysz stan plus, otrzymasz jednolicie losowy bit.
Jeśli układ jest w stanie
minus zamiast stanu plus, to pomiar działa
dokładnie tak samo.
Prawdopodobieństwa są ponownie równe 1/2 dla każdego możliwego wyniku.
Jedyna różnica jest taka, że znak plus zamienił się na minus, ale gdy bierzemy wartość
bezwzględną, nic się nie zmienia.
Jeśli zmierzymy ten stan qubit, prawdopodobieństwo otrzymania wyniku zero to kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej jeden plus dwa razy i
podzielone przez trzy, co wynosi 5/9,
a prawdopodobieństwo otrzymania wyniku jeden to kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej
minus 2/3, co wynosi 4/9.
I wreszcie, mierzenie
stanu bazy standardowej ket zero daje wynik
zero z pewnością, i podobnie, mierzenie stanu ket jeden
daje wynik jeden z pewnością. Dzieje się tak, bo kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej jedynki wynosi jeden.
Podobnie jak w przypadku probabilistycznym. Możemy skojarzyć te stany kwantowe, ket zero i ket jeden, z układem będącym w
tych stanach klasycznych,
i ten przykład jest zgodny
z tą interpretacją.
Teraz, tak jak w przypadku probabilistycznym, jeśli mierzymy układ, gdy
jest w stanie kwantowym,
to stan zmieni się ogólnie w wyniku
wykonania tego pomiaru.
W szczególności, i ponownie jest to dokładnie tak jak
w przypadku probabilistycznym.
Jeśli mierzymy układ i wynikiem pomiaru
jest stan klasyczny a, to nowy stan kwantowy
układu staje się ket a.
Więc dla tego stanu tutaj,
na przykład, widzimy to samo zachowanie,
które mieliśmy w przypadku probabilistycznym.
Jeśli zmierzymy, to z prawdopodobieństwem 5/9 otrzymamy wynik zero, w takim przypadku stan
przechodzi do ket zero,
a z prawdopodobieństwem
4/9 wynikiem jest jeden, i stan przechodzi do ket jeden.
Czasem to zjawisko jest nazywane kolapsem
stanu kwantowego, i jest to coś, co nie daje spać
osobom badającym podstawy
mechaniki kwantowej.
Ale z czysto
matematycznego punktu widzenia jest to naprawdę dość proste
i bardzo analogiczne do tego, co mamy w przypadku probabilistycznym.
Źródłem napięcia jest w pewnym sensie fundamentalna
natura stanów kwantowych i to, co reprezentują
i jak się różnią
od stanów probabilistycznych. Ale na poziomie matematycznym, być może jest to takie, czego można się spodziewać.
Zauważ nawiasem mówiąc, że jeśli
zmierzysz po raz drugi, to otrzymasz dokładnie
ten sam wynik co przy pierwszym pomiarze.
Istnieje więc limit ilości
informacji klasycznej, którą można wyodrębnić ze stanu kwantowego, i wrócimy do tego punktu wkrótce
w innej lekcji. Mówiliśmy o stanach kwantowych, jak również o pomiarach, a konkretnie o pomiarach w bazie standardowej,
które zapewniają sposób
wyodrębniania informacji klasycznej ze stanów kwantowych.
Pozostały temat
tej lekcji to operacje, konkretnie operacje unitarne, które opisują, jak
stany kwantowe układów
mogą być zmieniane. Naturalnie, skoro
wektory stanu kwantowego różnią się od wektorów prawdopodobieństwa, można oczekiwać, że zbiór
dopuszczalnych operacji
na stanach kwantowych różni się od tego, co mamy dla
informacji klasycznej, i rzeczywiście tak jest.
Podczas gdy operacje na stanach probabilistycznych są reprezentowane przez macierze stochastyczne, operacje na wektorach stanu kwantowego
są reprezentowane przez macierze unitarne.
Oto definicja macierzy unitarnych.
Kwadratowa macierz U mająca
elementy będące liczbami zespolonymi jest unitarna, jeśli spełnia równości,
które widzisz tutaj.
WEBVTT
Sztylet reprezentuje
sprzężony transponowany, który już widzieliśmy dla wektorów, gdy mówiliśmy o notacji Diraca chwilę temu.
Tutaj wykonujemy
sprzężony transponowany na macierzy zamiast na wektorze, ale jest to zasadniczo to samo.
Transponujemy macierz, co po prostu oznacza, że zamieniamy wiersze i kolumny, więc element JK staje się elementem KJ,
a także bierzemy sprzężenie zespolone
każdego elementu.
Ponadto ta notacja tutaj
oznacza macierz jednostkową.
Te dwie równości tutaj
są właściwie równoważne. Jeśli masz jedną, to
automatycznie masz drugą.
Obie są równoważne
powiedzeniu, że U jest odwracalna, a odwrotność jest równa
sprzężonemu transponowanemu.
To jest prawdziwe tylko dla
macierzy kwadratowych, nawiasem mówiąc. Jeśli masz macierz, która nie jest kwadratowa, to jedna z tych dwóch
równości może być prawdziwa,
ale wtedy ta druga nie będzie prawdziwa.
Ale tutaj mówimy
o macierzach kwadratowych.
To jest więc standardowa
definicja macierzy unitarnych i jest fajna, bo łatwo sprawdzić,
czy macierz jest unitarna.
Po prostu mnożysz macierz przez jej sprzężony transponowany z obu stron i sprawdzasz, czy otrzymujesz
macierz jednostkową.
Istnieje równoważny sposób charakteryzowania macierzy unitarnych, mianowicie że
kwadratowa macierz jest unitarna wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy nigdy nie zmienia normy euklidesowej
żadnego wektora przy mnożeniu. Macierz U rozmiaru N na N jest unitarna wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy norma euklidesowa U razy v
jest równa normie euklidesowej v dla każdego n-wymiarowego wektora kolumnowego v z elementami będącymi liczbami zespolonymi.
Dlatego, jeśli v jest
wektorem stanu kwantowego, to U razy v jest też
wektorem stanu kwantowego, ponieważ wektory stanu kwantowego
to po prostu wektory mające
normę euklidesową równą jeden.
Właściwie możemy powiedzieć trochę więcej, mianowicie że macierze unitarne są dokładnie macierzami, które zawsze przekształcają wektory stanu kwantowego
w wektory stanu kwantowego. To podobna sytuacja do tej, jaką mamy dla macierzy stochastycznych
i wektorów prawdopodobieństwa.
Macierze stochastyczne
są dokładnie macierzami, które zawsze przekształcają wektory prawdopodobieństwa w wektory prawdopodobieństwa.
Więc skoro zdecydowaliśmy, że operacje powinny być reprezentowane przez macierze, co jest równoznaczne z mówieniem, że transformacje działają liniowo
na wektorach reprezentujących stany, te wybory dotyczące zbiorów
dopuszczalnych operacji wynikają naturalnie, przynajmniej
w sensie matematycznym.
Teraz przyjrzyjmy się kilku przykładom unitarnych operacji qubitowych.
Zobaczymy wiele więcej przykładów
operacji unitarnych w kolejnych lekcjach, w tym operacje unitarne i układy
mające więcej niż dwa stany klasyczne. Ale na razie skupimy się tylko
na unitarnych operacjach qubitowych.
Będziemy widzieć te
konkretne przykłady pojawiające się znowu i znowu, więc zdecydowanie warto
poznać te operacje.
Pierwsza kolekcja przykładów to tzw. operacje Pauliego.
Są to operacje odpowiadające macierzom Pauliego, które są pokazane tutaj.
Wszystkie są unitarne i możesz to sprawdzić dla każdej z nich zgodnie z definicją z poprzedniego.
Te konkretne macierze
są równe swoim własnym sprzężonym transponowanym, co oznacza, że są
macierzami hermitowskimi.
Sprawdzenie, że są
wszystkie unitarne, w tym przypadku sprowadza się do podniesienia każdej z nich do kwadratu i sprawdzenia, że wynikiem
jest macierz jednostkowa.
Nazwy, które widzisz dla tych
macierzy, są dość standardowe, i zobaczysz też
sigma x, sigma y i sigma z nazywane po prostu X, Y i Z.
Należy jednak wiedzieć, że
wielkie litery X, Y i Z są też powszechnie używane w innych celach, nawet w kontekście
informacji kwantowej,
ale są to bardzo powszechne
nazwy tych macierzy.
Operacja sigma x lub X
jest też nazywana przerzutnikiem bitu lub operacją NOT, którą już widzieliśmy
w kontekście klasycznym.
A operacja sigma z lub Z jest też nazywana przerzutnikiem fazy.
I tutaj możesz zobaczyć
działanie tych operacji na wektorach bazy standardowej, co trochę wyjaśnia,
skąd te nazwy się biorą.
Z pewnością sensowne jest
odnoszenie się do sigma x jako przerzutnika bitu na podstawie tego działania tutaj.
Po prostu przerzuca bit z
zero na jeden lub z jeden na zero.
Sensowne jest też
nazywanie sigma z przerzutnikiem fazy na podstawie tego działania tutaj.
Ale jeśli nie jest to do końca jasne
w tej chwili, to jest ok.
Będziemy napotykać tę
operację raz za razem i znaczenie
postawienia znaku minus przed wektorem bazy ket jeden zamiast ket zero
i dlaczego to jest nazywane przerzutnikiem fazy, będzie jaśniejsze później.
Następny przykład to
operacja Hadamard, reprezentowana przez
tę macierz tutaj, która prawie zawsze jest oznaczana H.
Sprawdzenie, że H jest unitarne, jest ponownie
prostym obliczeniem, które, jeśli zejdę z drogi, możesz zobaczyć tutaj.
Podobnie jak macierze Pauliego, H jest swoim własnym sprzężonym transponowanym.
Mamy więc tę równość tutaj, i gdy wykonamy mnożenie, otrzymujemy macierz jednostkową, co jest wymagane.
WEBVTT
Trzeci przykład to
właściwie cała klasa operacji unitarnych
znanych jako operacje fazowe.
Są to operacje
reprezentowane przez dowolną macierz mającą tę postać,
którą widzisz tutaj, gdzie theta jest dowolną liczbą rzeczywistą.
Więc ten element tutaj będzie
zawsze pewną liczbą zespoloną na okręgu jednostkowym.
Macierze tej postaci są zawsze unitarne, co zostawiam tobie do weryfikacji.
Tym razem sprzężony transponowany nie będzie równy oryginalnej macierzy, chyba że ta liczba tutaj jest jedynką lub minus jedynką,
w takim przypadku otrzymujemy
albo macierz jednostkową albo sigma z, którą
już napotkaliśmy.
Konkretnie, transponowanie
niczego nie zrobi z tą macierzą, ale wzięcie sprzężenia zespolonego każdego elementu zmienia ten element tutaj
na e do potęgi minus i theta.
Te dwie konkretne operacje tutaj są szczególnie ważnymi
przykładami operacji fazowych.
Dla pierwszej z nich, bierzemy
theta równe pi przez dwa i otrzymujemy tę macierz tutaj.
Jest to powszechnie nazywane operacją S lub gate S, gdy mówimy o circuit, co nie będziemy omawiać w tej lekcji,
ale to ważny
temat, który pojawi się wkrótce.
Druga to ta operacja. Jest to operacja T lub gate T.
Dla tej z kolei theta
jest równe pi przez cztery. Więc gdy obliczamy wykładniczą, otrzymujemy tę wartość tutaj, czyli jeden plus i przez
pierwiastek kwadratowy z dwóch.
Oto kilka szybkich przykładów, by zobaczyć kilka z tych
operacji w działaniu.
Oto działanie
operacji Hadamard na ket zero i ket jeden.
Jeśli przejdziemy przez
mnożenie macierzy przez wektor, widzimy, że to, co otrzymujemy, to stan plus i stan
minus odpowiednio.
Jeśli wykonamy operację Hadamard na stanie plus i stanie
minus z kolei, wrócimy do ket zero i ket jeden.
Więc jeśli trochę to uporządkujemy, możemy zobaczyć działanie wyraźniej.
Operacja Hadamard
przekształca z powrotem i z powrotem między stanem zero i stanem plus oraz między stanem jeden
i stanem minus.
W odniesieniu do tych dwóch równań tutaj, zauważ, że daje nam to prosty sposób wykrywania różnicy między stanem plus i stanem minus.
Jak widzieliśmy wcześniej w lekcji, jeśli zmierzymy stan plus
i stan minus względem pomiaru
w bazie standardowej,
w obu przypadkach otrzymujemy jednolicie losowy bit, co nie pomaga nam
wykryć różnicy.
Ale jeśli wykonamy operację Hadamard
a potem zmierzymy, zobaczymy zero, jeśli
oryginalny stan był stanem plus
i jeden, jeśli oryginalny
stan był stanem minus.
Te dwa stany są więc rzeczywiście różne i można je doskonale odróżnić
metodą, którą właśnie opisałem,
czyli najpierw wykonaj
operację Hadamard a potem zmierz.
Wracając do przykładu
stanu qubit, który widzieliśmy wcześniej, który nie jest szczególnie specjalny, możemy zobaczyć, co operacja Hadamard
robi ze stanem
przez konwersję do form,
które widzisz tutaj, i wykonanie mnożenia.
A oto wynik,
który możemy przekonwertować z powrotem do notacji Diraca, jeśli chcemy,
i to jest jeden sposób obliczania
tych działań.
Oto inny przykład ilustrujący, że nie zawsze
trzeba jawnie konwertować do postaci macierz-wektor.
Można też wykonywać te
obliczenia bezpośrednio używając notacji Diraca.
Ten przykład dotyczy operacji T i oto ona
tutaj dla odniesienia.
Ta operacja ma to działanie tutaj na stanach bazy standardowej.
I jeśli chcemy obliczyć
działanie operacji T na stanie plus na przykład, możemy zacząć od rozwinięcia
definicji stanu plus
a potem użyć liniowości,
by wyrazić wynik tak jak widzisz tutaj.
Możemy teraz po prostu podstawić
te wyrażenia tutaj, zrobić tylko trochę
uproszczenia dla drugiego wyrazu, i otrzymujemy wynik.
Jeśli z jakiegokolwiek powodu chcielibyśmy zastosować operację Hadamard
do wyniku, możemy zrobić podobną rzecz.
Najpierw podstawiamy wyrażenie dla T działającego na stanie plus i używamy liniowości jak poprzednio.
A teraz, jeśli podstawimy
wyrażenia, które już mamy dla operacji Hadamard
działającej na ket zero i ket jeden,
otrzymujemy to. A teraz możemy rozwinąć stan plus i stan minus, by dostać to wyrażenie tutaj,
które możemy uprościć przez dodawanie, i oto ostateczny wynik.
Nie ma nic szczególnie
specjalnego w tym przykładzie. Ma on jedynie
ilustrować ten alternatywny, ale równoważny sposób obliczania działań
tych operacji. Możesz używać
metody, która jest wygodniejsza w danej sytuacji.
Ostatnia uwaga o
operacjach unitarnych jest taka, że złożenia operacji unitarnych są reprezentowane przez mnożenie macierzy
tak jak w przypadku probabilistycznym, tzn. możesz obliczyć działanie sekwencji operacji unitarnych
przez proste pomnożenie
macierzy razem. I otrzymasz
pojedynczą macierz unitarną reprezentującą złożone działanie
WEBVTT
sekwencji operacji.
Tak jak w przypadku macierzy stochastycznych, macierze unitarne są
domknięte ze względu na mnożenie, więc zawsze otrzymasz macierz unitarną
składając operacje unitarne.
Musisz upewnić się,
że mnożysz macierze w prawidłowej kolejności.
Ale sposób, w jaki to działa, jest taki sam jak w przypadku operacji stochastycznych, gdzie macierz dla
pierwszej operacji, którą wykonujesz,
zawsze pojawi się po prawej stronie
iloczynu macierzy, a ostatnia pojawi się
po lewej stronie.
Tak więc, podobnie jak poprzednio, kolejność jest odwrócona w tym sensie, że składasz od prawej do lewej, a nie od lewej do prawej.
Oto interesujący przykład, który daje operację zwaną pierwiastkiem kwadratowym z NOT.
Załóżmy, że najpierw
stosujemy operację Hadamard, po niej operację S, a po niej kolejną operację Hadamard.
Złożone działanie
tych trzech operacji jest opisane przez ten iloczyn.
Tutaj jest pierwsza operacja Hadamard, tutaj jest operacja S, a tutaj jest druga operacja Hadamard.
Jeśli wykonamy mnożenie macierzy, które nie jest tutaj jawnie pokazane, ale możesz to zrobić
sam/-a, jeśli chcesz,
wynikiem jest ta macierz tutaj. Jest to macierz unitarna i możemy to sprawdzić bezpośrednio
lub możemy polegać na fakcie, że macierze unitarne są
domknięte ze względu na mnożenie.
Musi być unitarna, ponieważ te trzy macierze są unitarne, jak już widzieliśmy.
Nie mamy tutaj żadnego konkretnego
wektora stanu kwantowego na myśli.
Możemy sobie wyobrazić stosowanie
tej sekwencji operacji na dowolnym wektorze stanu kwantowego, a ta macierz opisuje działanie.
Powód, dla którego ta złożona operacja, czyli ta opisana
przez tę macierz tutaj, jest nazywana pierwiastkiem kwadratowym z NOT,
jest taki, że przez wykonanie jej
dwa razy otrzymujemy operację NOT, lub innymi słowy,
operację sigma x lub X.
Wykonanie operacji
dwa razy jest reprezentowane przez podniesienie macierzy do kwadratu lub
pomnożenie jej przez siebie.
I jeśli to zrobisz, zobaczysz, że wynikiem
jest macierz Pauliego x.
I to jest dość osobliwe i daje ci tylko namiastkę tego, że możesz robić pewne interesujące rzeczy z informacją kwantową, których nie możesz robić z
informacją klasyczną.
Nie istnieje żadna klasyczna operacja, czyli taka reprezentowana
przez macierz stochastyczną, która daje operację NOT,
jeśli wykonamy ją dwa razy.
Jest to więc dobry przykład, który ujawnia, że operacje kwantowe
zachowują się bardzo inaczej niż operacje klasyczne.
I to tyle na temat lekcji pierwszej. W tej lekcji omówiliśmy, jak działa informacja kwantowa dla pojedynczych układów w izolacji,
a w następnej lekcji porozmawiamy o tym, jak
działa informacja kwantowa dla wielu układów.
Dziękuję za oglądanie. Jeśli masz jakieś pytania, śmiało zostaw je w
sekcji komentarzy poniżej.